one of the questions he touched upon was
the question of efficient proof search
or automatability
and we're our next talk will deal I
think specifically with this topic so
Robert Robert from Miguel will give us a
survey about automate reality
thanks Jacob and thanks to the
organizers for inviting me to give this
talk so like he said I'm gonna give a
survey about automatability which is
kind of the the proof theory that the
proof complexity way of analyzing uh
proof search
um okay so let's start off with the
basic question uh automatability what is
it so
um here's a picture of a SAT solver
um so a stat solver as input get to get
some CNF formula uh and then we feed
into this nice algorithm a and it's
going to tell me if it's satisfiable or
if it's not satisfiable right easy peasy
done now however the stat solver by
itself is not only going to just tell us
if it's sad or not sad it's also going
to provide some witness for these facts
right so on the one hand if it's
actually satisfied it's going to give us
a satisfying assignment in fact that's
usually the information piece of
information we're actually interested in
finding
um and if it's unsatisfiable and if
we've turned on proof logging or
whatever uh then it's going to return
that it's unsatisfiable and it will also
certify this by giving a refutation of
that formula right like a proof that
it's not true
and so the way that we can think about
this is that if I just ignore the
satisfiable satisfiable case I could
take any tautology and negate it and
I'll get a contradiction and now I can
think about this set silver as a kind of
automated fear improver if you like
right if I run some to talk some
contradiction through this say the
negation of a tautology I run it through
well it's going to spit out a proof that
this thing is a contradiction which is
of course a proof that the original
formula was a tautology
that makes sense
okay great
so now well unfortunately we're not in a
world where these things run efficiently
all the time so in particular uh this
thing is not going to run efficiently no
matter what uh on all inputs because
well we broadly believe that P is
different from NP but in fact the
situation is a little bit worse right
because of the one-sided nature
of NP
um if I feed in an unsatisfiable formula
uh it's it's not even necessarily going
to be able to Output a short proof of
this thing
right so
um and this is I mean the the complexity
theory of saying this is that we believe
that NP is different from co-np but
um this means that well I mean one way
to think about this in an applied
setting is that proof logging might be a
lot more expensive than simply just uh
than not doing that right
and so you know there's lots of lots and
lots of examples we saw some examples in
Albert's talk but uh for example I mean
any resolution refutation and resolution
is kind of the one of the systems that's
that uh a lot of stats offers do they're
sort of reasoning in there's a lot of
stars to put on that statement but bear
with me
um any resolution reputation of the
Pinot principle requires exponential
size so even if you plug these
relatively simple formulas in any proof
it's going to Output is going to
necessarily be large
so
obvious question then is the following
can we design a solver such that the
length of the refutation that gets
output
is never far from optimal like never far
from the length of the shortest proof
right it might take exponential time in
fact it's going to have to sometimes
right if we believe that NP is not equal
to Coen P which is in my opinion a
believable assumption
but maybe we can still find a proof
that's not too far from this exponential
length Optimum
does that make sense
and that's exactly what the
automatability question that's exactly
what the automatability question is
asking so here's some notation so if p
is a proof system and I have some
tautology C I'm going to use this S Sub
P of C to denote the length of the
shortest P proof of fee okay
and now I'll say that a proof this proof
system is T of s automatable by another
proof system Q
if there's an algorithm that given any
tautology is input is going to Output a
q proof of this formula in time bounded
by the length of the shortest P proof of
the formula
so in other words this algorithm is
going to give me it's going to give me a
tautology and it's going to Output a
proof of betatology maybe in a different
proof system I don't really care
um you know like the stat solvers that
exist they'll output drap groups or
something like that not a resolution
proof but the important part is that the
amount of time it's going to take is
proportional to the length of the
shortest proof of C
okay
so
um
in particular I'll say that this proof
system is weakly automatable
if there's if it can be polynomial bound
like automatable up to a polynomial
Factor off of the length of the shortest
proof by some proof system Q like being
very relaxed here
and I'll say it's even stronger I'll say
it's automatable if it actually gives me
a p proof
does that make sense
any questions about this sort of
definition
okay good
and now hopefully that we we can agree
that at least from sort of an algae like
a like a theory of algorithms
perspective that this problem captures
the proof search problem right as a
theoretical algorithmic problem right so
given the tautology we want to actually
find a proof of that thing and we want
to get some reasonable bound on the
runtime of that
okay
good
so now um related to the search version
of this problem I want to actually bring
up another variant of this problem which
is like never really mentioned but I
think it's important to talk about it
um and that's kind of the decision
variant of this problem
um which I'm going to in honor of the
meta complexity program that we're
attending that the uh I'll call mpsp for
the minimum proof size problem so what
is this well this is a decision problem
now and you're given a formula and some
positive integer and I'm going to ask if
this formula has a p proof of length
that most k
okay so this is a decision problem the
answer is either yes or no
um and so
one can ask okay well is this problem
hard right well clearly it's in NP
right if you give me a formula I can
just guess the proof and guess and check
that it's less than length K and then
actually verify that it is a p proof by
just checking so it's obviously an NP
but the interesting thing about this
problem is that it's actually known to
be NP complete for many proof systems
and this has even been known all the way
since the 90s so for resolution for
instance iwama approved in 97 that it's
NP complete to to find such a thing for
these like stronger proof systems like
frega extended frega polynomial calculus
in fact this proof technique from this
paper is very general it applies to many
different proof many different problems
we can already show that it's NP
complete
so in some sense
proof search is hard right we already
knew that in the 90s right
so uh what's going on here that's my
first question for the audience
so these MP completeness results do not
imply that automatability is NP card why
is that immediately
why why even study automatability I
already know the proofs are just hard
why
why okay why well the answer is that
um if you go back to what automatability
was saying
we're going to be automatable if I'm
allowed to be off by the optimal proof
like by a polynomial Factor
but as is the usual thing in NP
completeness well if I if all I need to
show that this is NP complete is to
differ between say K and K plus one
right maybe finding that what this tells
us is that maybe finding the difference
between a proof of length K versus
finding a proof of length K plus one
that's NP complete but it doesn't tell
me anything about a polynomial Factor
off an approximability
make sense
and I think that this is actually a
reasonable thing this actually motivates
automated abilities something to study
because it's yeah you're saying it's
like the difference between pinning down
exactly whether it's a proof of length K
yeah or whether there is a proof of any
reasonable language exactly right
exactly right yeah
so this is good and I wanted people to
keep this in mind because we'll come
back to this later
um
so
um when we come back to this so when we
think about this polynomial
approximation
um we can we should just ask you know
okay well is it possible at all like the
existing NP completeness results didn't
rule it out and the short answer to this
question is that it depends so on the
positive side well for any proof system
P I can always find a proof in time this
is a very boring answer 2 to the length
of the proof why well um a proof is a
bit string and I can just uh brute force
over all the bit strings and just check
and see if the bit string that I saw in
front of me is a proof right okay so
that's an exponential time automating
algorithm it does actually give us some
at least
um
on the other hand if I look at weaker
proof systems say resolution uh it turns
out that we can actually beat this
runtime you can actually do better than
this 2 to the s to the p
um and other Notions of automate ability
if we relax it a little bit like Notions
of degree or width automate ability this
was kind of already alluded to
um in Albert's talk these turn out to be
achievable actually quite efficiently
in many senses so in some sense the the
positive side the uh the answer is yes
on the other hand on the negative side
it turns out that getting polynomially
bounded automatability is actually often
in PR and this is true even for
resolution thanks to this beautiful work
of Albert and Mortimer
and the long answer I guess is the rest
of this talk so
um yeah
any questions about this sort of so far
um okay well here's uh the proof system
zoo and uh I borrowed by which I mean
stole this slide from Susanna who's not
here so oh she's here oh dang it
uh so um here's the proof systems that
I'll honestly considering this is far
from a complete picture of all the proof
systems that we've seen uh that that
that people study in practice but I
think it's uh Illuminating for
unmutability
um so let's talk about both upper bounds
and lower bounds what's known in terms
of automatability okay so in this
picture so um red is going to mean that
we have no non-trivial upper Bound for
automating proofs in the system okay so
if I look at any of these red proof
systems the best algorithm that I really
know of to get a uh to automated proof
is just by doing this Brute Force
checking bit by bit okay the two to the
S is the best we can look for
for these blue systems we can do
something slightly better
we can use upper bounds from width and
degree or other tricks there's multiple
ways to get these improved mounts but we
can use some some non-trivial upper
bounds in order to get something better
okay and for this very special case of
tree like resolution we there's a
there's a non-trivial algorithm like a
like a a clever one which we'll see
later that's really doesn't use width or
doesn't relax with these things and here
we get a better upper bound and it turns
out that this upper bound is tight
assuming some reasonable complexity
theoretic conjectures
okay
on the other hand if we contrast this to
the lower bound side
so some of these colors have changed I
hope good
um
well here it's kind of easiest to divide
these things up in terms of the
strengths of things in terms of the
strengths of assumptions so up here for
these very very strong proof systems
if we assume things like cryptography
some standard assumptions in
cryptography then we can show that it's
already this might be small but we can
show it's already exponentially hard to
even weekly automate these group systems
um down on the bottom side
assuming NP is different from P we can
get lower bounds on automation but we
can't get any lower bounds on on weak
Automation and then we have this
annoying middle slice of proof systems
that I've drawn here where we can't
really say anything at all so we should
think of the world as kind of like this
so on the high side of proof systems
once the proof systems become very very
rich
um well assuming cryptography then we
don't even get weak automatic ability
once the proof systems are kind of weak
well we can relax this assumption and
assuming P naught equal MP we will not
get automatability but this doesn't rule
out the possibility that we could weakly
automate it in some stronger fruit
system and for tree-like resolution
we've almost completely understood what
automatability is possible here so like
assuming eth we know exactly the run
time of the best algorithm and we have
that algorithmet that achieves it
this is definitely not it would be super
cool if you could turn this into
invisible gift but yeah I don't know how
to do that
um okay so this was my bird's eye view
are there any questions about this so
far
foreign
problem but we have algorithms that can
solve lots of practical instances let's
say yeah efficiency how does the
situation look like for the minimum
proof size problem do we have some oh
that's a great question
um
yeah do people actually uh study this
problem
um I think that the algorithms that
solve this problem are basically just
simulates act solving so like I don't
know if there's anything more geared
specifically towards this is that your
question yes yeah yeah I don't know of
anything that's more geared to just
solving this decision version just
trying to differentiate between their
existing improved versus actually
producing it in some sense right like in
some sense if I'm trying to give it like
an actual deterministic algorithm for
solving this problem I guess or no way
since that this algorithm is going to be
a certificate anyway so it's kind of
hard to escape proving things at the end
of the day
yeah
I don't know
anyway uh where does it extended
I've heard about something called
extended resolution
where does that fit in yeah that's
extended fragment that's the same as
extended frigate yeah extended
resolution and extended frego are the
same system I was just allowed to
introduce a new level
yeah that's exactly right yeah and
that's uh on the picture back here sorry
it's all the way up here at the very top
okay
uh any other questions
the answer is that it depends
um the stronger the proof system is the
weaker assumption you need so like for
extended Fraga all you need is like
uh maybe factoring is hard
um or maybe maybe even Computing an RSA
pair like proving that that's secure
um once you get down to the weaker proof
system weaker quote-unquote proof
systems you need to make the crypto
assumptions stronger in order to get
them yeah but if you're happy with
extended Fraga then you can just say
back
it was another point
just because
it doesn't necessarily mean
yeah absolutely true yeah absolutely
true it's the uh whether or not
resolution is weakly automatable is a
great open problem yeah yeah
perfect
I think that this is actually a really
nice problem in particular because these
these as I understand it these set
solvers that use u-rad and things like
that because it's kind of like a weak
automated ability procedures because
it's outputting it's logging it doesn't
log a resolution proof it kind of does
the reasoning and resolution in some
sense because it's branching on queries
and doing unit propagation we all know
those steps can be simulated by a
resolution but when it logs the proof it
logs it as a drap proof which is a very
different system but much stronger right
well except that they mostly just use
syrup which is a variant of resolution
and there's only very few steps that
make use of the extension the threat
I guess it
it's only uh pre-processing technique
known as bounded variable Edition which
basically inserts a new variable and
retracting supplies
a very minor pre-processing step okay
cool thanks thanks extra clarification
okay great
so in the rest of the talk what I want
to do is I want to kind of show everyone
both went back too far I want to show
everybody both the upper bound side and
the lower bound side so please thanks
um a lot of effort a lot of effort goes
into the lower bound side but I think
the upper bound side is also worth kind
of seeing what we can theoretically
prove so let's start by talking about
upper bounds
and uh in particular I'm going to focus
on the case of of resolution entry like
resolutions as it's going to be a
familiar proof system for everybody
uh so here's a slide that I'm gonna
that's just for completeness so let's
define a resolution proof just so that
we're on the same page so resolution as
we all know it's a Hilbert style
deductive system the lines are clauses
which are horrors of literals
um we're given two proof rules uh the
resolution rule
um and this weakening rule where I can
just add in some extra literals to a
clause if I want it you don't actually
need this weakening rule it's just handy
to have it around sometimes when you're
proving things
um the length of the proof is the number
of lines in it
the depth of the proof is going to be
the length of the longest path if I draw
the proof out like a dag so here the
depth would be four I guess one two
three four
um the width of a proof is the size of
the largest Clause that appears in it so
here it would be three because we have
this Clause right here that has a size
three
um and I'll say it's a tree like a proof
If any derived Clause gets used at most
ones okay so this is a proof of with 10
Clauses
um it has width three depth four it's
not a tree like proof because this
Clause that's derived got used more than
once so but I could always turn it into
a tree like proof how well
just take whatever Clause that was used
more than once and then just derive it
twice and then just recursively split
this will cause an exponential blow up
in the proof size but whatever I can
still do the conversion
does that make sense okay good this is
all review I'm sure
um so let's talk about um how do we
actually automate resolution well let's
first start with um
for lack of a better name I'm going to
call the dumb algorithm
um and that's the following I've already
said it in words earlier so as input I
get my CNF formula
and then for s that just goes on forever
and for every binary string of like s
I'm just going to check if this string
encodes a resolution refutation of F and
if so I'll return it
does that make sense this thing's not
even guaranteed to Halt so I'm going to
assume this thing's unsatisfiable let's
not worry about that kind of detail okay
but this is an algorithm if you give me
an unsatisfiable thing it's complete
it's certainly an automating algorithm
right like given any tautology it'll
output a resolution proof of it
um
and this is the in some sense the
obvious Brute Force algorithm
um this works for any proof system at
all right I can just if as long as I can
test that something is approved which is
a requirement for a proof system I can
write down this algorithm for it
um
and what's the runtime of it well if you
work it out it runs in time I mean this
is a this is an exponential time Loop in
the thing so it's totally dominated by
the largest s so we're going to get
something like order s the size of the
shortest proof times two to the size the
shortest proof which is I'll just be
lazy and write it like this two to the
order the length of the shortest proof
that makes sense so basically what this
is doing is it's just brute forcing over
all proofs until I find them
um okay so that's great
um in the sense that it's very simple to
analyze this algorithm it does verify
that we have some kind of slow thing but
can we do better
uh well
um
one the the way that we can do better is
by using the following observation
so instead of just looking at the length
of the proof we're going to instead look
at the width of the largest Clause
inside
so here's a really obvious observation I
guess if I have n variables and I count
up the number of Clauses with the most W
well how many are there well there's
going to be something like end of the
order W right the proof of this is right
here I mean the number of with W Clauses
exactly this expression right here I
choose I literals to go and like I
choose I variables to go in my claws and
I have to give them all signs
that's two to the I times
good
well then once when I know this you can
now Define this uh width automating
algorithm okay and what this algorithm
is going to do is it's going to return
if a proof exists it's going to return a
proof where every Clause has a width at
most w
okay so how does this work well I get my
formula and I get some parameter W as
the input
and then I start with my proof by
throwing in all the axioms
and then as long as I haven't finished
like I haven't derived a contradiction
or until maybe the proof doesn't change
like I can't derive anything new I'll
just do the following for every single
pair just resolve them together if I can
and then append it to the proof this the
new Clause is loaded
does that make sense
very simple very simple proof
um if and then once uh the bottom it
returns and once the the empty Clause
appears and my proof I'll return it
otherwise I'll fail because then there
is no with W proof
thank you
foreign okay good
so what's nice about this proof is that
it actually runs in much better time
right if there is a constant width
resolution refutation right then this is
going to Output that constant width
refutation in polynomial time right if
if there's a reputation of width seven
of my formula well then this is going to
Output it at least in Time end of the
seventh which is much much better than
just brute forcing the world yeah
you're eliminating the original Clauses
from the Swiss uh computation right
no I'm counting them yeah that's a
that's a subtle Point yeah so if my
original guy uh if these guys uh have
big width then I need to count that yeah
you do need to count that you can always
now you can always
um you know do like a Satan
transformation and plastic out of 3cnet
or something yeah
so yeah so this is algorithm runs the
time into the W it outputs a with W
Clause with W refutation if one exists
um but I'm gonna note here that
um
low-width reputations might not always
exist right so uh it's not an easy fact
but it turns out that there are constant
width CNF formulas that require
basically linear with jurisity like you
more or less have to look at every
single variable in your formula in order
to receive it
okay so what this says is that if I
wanted to run this algorithm up to W for
w equals 0 1 all the way up this tells
you that maybe you have to go all the
way up to n
right
however it turns out that you don't
actually always have to go all the way
up to end you can actually do slightly
better than that
and that follows from this beautiful
size width relationship through the
business on bigerson which I've stated
here and it says the following if you
give me any unsatisfiable CNF formula on
N variables
well then the width it's going to take
to refute that formula
is bounded by roughly square root n
times the log of the size of the feeding
that formula
quite interesting right because if if I
have what this is telling you is that if
I have a polynomial size proof
say like something like n to the
constant here well that's going to turn
into square root N I only it suffices to
look only up to with square root n
and this tells you immediately just by
running this algorithm that we just saw
that you can automate resolution in a
highly non-trivial runtime much much
better than just this 2 to the s that we
saw now we're giving something like 2 to
the square root n log s
the some login factors being kind of
suppressed
does that make sense
so I'm not going to prove this theorem
but I but but I will point out that this
is a really highly non-trivial thing
like this really does improve on the
dumb Brute Force algorithm for
resolution like this is always going to
do better than
yourself
um now the downside of course is that it
is a sub-exponential Time
it's still running in something like
exponential in N weekly exponential and
N but it's it's still it is doing much
better it is handily sort of beating
this Brute Force
does that make sense
okay cool
um well I said earlier that um
oh yeah sure
this is true only if you have a problem
inside
yeah it's parameterized by the proof
size here so it doesn't matter if I have
an exponential size proof then this will
just collapse to two to the end yeah
which will be everything will just sort
of the numbers will sort of work out
Robert
and also the case that they're solving
different problems like the dumb
algorithm is finding the smallest proof
you're right I'll get back to that this
is
Okay cool so that's the amount of tree
light resolution so I said second ago
that we had this kind of um ad hoc
algorithm that sort of does better for
tree like this pollution it actually
gets the right well let's first
um let's first think about it this
algorithm that we just showed you this
does not automate tree light resolution
so why is that
right the true resolution can have a
retire away you could bound the width of
a tree resolution proof actually
there's nothing special about it yeah
you could consider Downing between three
resolution
that's true yeah yeah but I could always
run it for width one two you know what I
mean just like I just did that's not
quite the answer
producing three light proofs exactly the
algorithm is not going to produce a tree
like proof right it will produce a proof
but it might produce a dag like first
and if you look at this width algorithm
it's certainly going to be doing dag
like uh deduction steps right like I'm
really not putting any control over what
I'm doing here I'm just blindly
resolving things together as long as I
can so it's probably going to be a big
mess very highly dag like it can be very
far from a tree like proof right
so this algorithm does not automate
tree-like resolution and it's really
important to keep these things in mind
that you might think that
um automatability is somehow monotone
right like if a if a system as a system
gets stronger maybe I can uh maybe an
automating algorithm will somehow work
its way back down but this is not true
right we have to be careful about these
kinds of things
but it does turn out that you can
actually automate tree like resolution
this is due to theme potassium in 96.
and the runtime that they get is
actually much better than the runtime
that you got for uh the automating
algorithm for
um resolution it's actually just end of
the law yes we've just eliminated this
Square this uh n in the exponent
completely this is a quasi-polynomial
Time automating algorithm
so how do we compare this with the thing
that we just seen well on the one hand
um this is much faster than just
automating resolution right but on the
other hand tree-like proofs can be much
larger than dag-like resolution proofs
like there's exponential separations
between the two and it's very important
that in this exponent we get like an uh
you know this the exponent is in the
size of the smallest tree resolution
proof and not in terms of the size of
the smallest Resolution Group
does that make sense
okay cool
well how does this algorithm work well I
can sketch it for you
so here's my tree like resolution proof
so it starts with some formula f and uh
we have some my proof is p and sales
eventually to do some of the empty class
so how can we find this proof well the
idea is the following we're going to
look at the last resolution step that
occurred in the proof okay so it
resolved on some variable x sub I which
means we can now split the proof into
two totally distinct sub-proofs uh Pi L
and Pi sub r and because the uh the
graph of the proof is a tree we know
that at least one of these two pieces is
going to have at most half of the proof
length
now this is great because as soon as
you've dropped the size of anything by a
constant Factor you should start
thinking recursion right and that's
exactly where the log s and the exponent
is going to turn up in okay
um so what are we going to do well if I
look at these two subproofs what you
could do is you can restrict x i on this
side to be false
and you can restrict x i on this side to
be true and now I get two little
refutations of the restricted formula f
for Circuit by x i is zero and F
restricted to x i is
so now if I can recursively solve these
two sub problems
I can patch them the idea is to patch
them back together
and it turns out that this is possible
if I have a reputation of a restricted
formula well I can turn I can just take
that same sequence of resolutions and
weakenings that happened and on the
original formula it'll just give me a
proof of X of I
does that make sense
so this means okay if I have a tree
reputation of size of most s will I get
a tree reputation of one of these two
sub problems of size at most s so now I
have my recursion all set up what am I
going to do for every literal in the
formula
I'm just going to set that literal to
false and to true
okay and I'll recurse on these two sub
problems and I'll do it and I'll do them
in parallel
I know that on one of the sides the size
of it is going to drop by at least half
right
um on the other side the size of the
proof might not drop but I do know that
the number of variables decreased by one
because I fixed it right so on both
sides we're making some progress
and then once I've solved these two sub
problems I can just use my fact and
recombine them back into a proof of the
original thing
okay good so this you plug this in you
you figure out what the recurrence
relation is for the runtime you solve it
and it turns out to be something like
end of the log s okay the dominating
step here is really
um you know at least on one side we
divide by two every time so it's going
to be log s stages and we have to do
like order n choices order n branches at
the top so it should be something like
end of the law guess hopefully that's
believable
does that make sense
okay
and hopefully you can see like here
we're really taking advantage of the
tree-like structure we're using the fact
that the proof on one side and the proof
on the other side really don't talk to
each other right I can really just sort
of shove those off solve them completely
independently and then recombine them
this kind of argument really doesn't
work for the dag like setting
is there any questions about that
okay great
so let's move on to talking about some
of these algebraic systems that um
Albert mentioned in his talk I'm not
going to go into great detail because I
don't want to
um
I don't want to spend the time to sort
of Define them and things like that
um but let me just say that these
algebraic systems they also admit a form
of this width automatability that we saw
a second ago
um so the proof systems for these these
algebraic proof systems are composed of
algebraic expressions so polynomial
identities or inequalities and it turns
out that
um you can find degree D proofs in these
systems in time roughly into the D
it's like in resolution you could find
with W proofs in time roughly n to the W
but you need more sophisticated
techniques than just brute forcing uh up
to something because I'm dealing with a
richer set of lines in my proofs right
so uh throw up a table of what you can
kind of do in order to get these things
so safer you know you can use things
like gaussian elimination for no selling
stats for polynomial calculus you need
something like robner bases and then for
the semi-algebraic systems you need
linear semi-definite programming with a
little caveat that you need to watch the
sizes of the coefficients here
um but let me just say that these it
turns out that you can still do degree
automatability under some mild
assumptions in all of these systems
and this is nice because these weak
algebraic systems
with the exception of millstone stats
but I'll mention that in a second
also satisfy this size degree relation
just like resolution does right so if I
take polymer calculus or trolley atoms
or something squares again with a little
bit of coefficient size caveat for these
things but let's not worry about it
um
the degree the lowest degree proof of
these systems is going to have exactly
the same expression in the exponent as
with resolution something like square
root n Times log of the princess
does that make sense
so as a corollary we can do the exact
same thing we can automate these systems
also in time roughly n to the square
root analogous
and now I've only named three systems
here so you might be worried about no
stone sets
um my understanding is that I didn't
actually know this but I learned this
like a week ago but apparently you can
modify the tree like resolution proof to
get the same bound
so null cell and sets does not satisfy
this relation provably does not satisfy
this relation but in terms of there's an
alternate method to get the same upper
Bound in the uh in the peripheral storm
attack but let's just sweep that aside
for a second
okay cool
and that for upper bounds is actually
all we essentially know for all of these
stronger per systems we really do not
know anything positive for
automatability Beyond this stupid Brute
Force algorithm where you just blast out
all the bits and just you should verify
that it is actually a proof of the right
type
and I think it's an excellent problem to
try and understand can you for these
stronger proof systems can you even get
something that slightly beats Brute
Force search like it's it's really not
obvious to me that you can that you can
do that but but for resolution you can
like what's what's the difference we
know the proofs can be much shorter
asking for you to do is beat two to the
S right like just by a little bit it's
uh this is a really really nice problem
somehow
uh okay any questions about that the
upper bound section yeah awesome uh if
you use extension variables on Rescue
vessel again what you what can you get
in yeah okay you you do
for rescue you are the m to the K
variable so that represents conjunction
and then you run resolution oh yeah
that's a good question actually
uh
[Music]
is the issue but you might get something
like that yeah because you have an
unbounded fan in the horse but something
you could say Robert I forget to tell
him but you should also repeat the
question because there are some people
attending oh sorry sorry thank you I'm
sorry for not mentioning this before
yeah so the question was uh for res K
which is like intuitively a perfect
system where the lines are pores of low
width ands maybe you could just reduce
to the resolution automatability by just
replacing every and by a variable and
just then running me out or then we just
saw I'm worried about the width of the
OR at the top maybe there's something
you could do yeah
that's true everything is deterministic
um for randomization as far as we know
it doesn't help for certifying for
satisfiability it seems uncertainty
it might be a bug in my book but I think
my book refers to a randomized algorithm
that will find a short proof If it
exists oh okay okay
okay what we'd love to hear about it
then yeah
oh yeah
you said that better than Brute Force
algorithms would be nice are there like
better algorithms to lower bound
connections from better than truthful
great question yeah the none that I know
of totally unexplored like not that it
doesn't exist but just totally expert
what was the question uh so you just ask
a question
question what's up was um are there like
could you somehow take the lack of
better than Brute Force algorithms and
maybe convert them into something like
maybe if I can beat Brute Force even
slightly for extended Fraga maybe some
other surprising connection maybe some
other surprising result would follow and
I don't know of any such connection
let's move on to the lower bound portion
which is the part where all the sad
people go
um
it's just my experience from talking to
sad people
okay what we're all set we're all sad
people okay yeah and the whole audience
went
okay great
um okay so let's forget about the
detailed thing and let's just think
about the sort of uh rough separation
between crypto people's MP so let's
first talk about how we can use crypto
to rule out weak automatability okay
um and I'm gonna I'm actually gonna
pretty much just completely prove this
modulus some pretty significant hand
weights but it's it's it's that's yeah
if you can take that thing uh
um so how how do these proof systems
work well how do these how do these
results work sorry so the basic idea is
the following so I'm going to informally
Define
um a crypto a cryptographic object it's
called a one-way permutation
uh and a one-way permutation is just a
family of functions each of them is a
permutation like each of them permutes
say that the strings of length n uh and
their polynomial time computable
but they're hard to invert so I mean if
you give me some string in the image
it's going to be hard for me to find
something in the pre-image on average it
turns out that if this is true it's hard
to even predict any some bit in the in
the pre-image on average
this is a pretty standard cryptographic
assumption that these things exist I'll
say that this is stronger than necessary
you don't really need an assumption this
strong but this is just going to
simplify the presentation a little bit
um and the whole idea of doing this goes
back to a paper by cry check and putlock
which shows that if we can weekly
automate these strong proof systems
uh well then we can actually use this
automation algorithm to somehow invert a
one-way permutation
so um project and putlock sort of did
this for extended Fraga although they
they did it mostly in the language it
bounded arithmetic
um for weaker proof systems like
tc0frega and ac0 frega and frega this
was sort of done by uh Bonnet potassium
Ross
um
and the key word here is feasible is
something called feasible interpolation
which if you've been to proof complexity
talks before you've probably seen it but
we're not even don't even worry about it
I'm just gonna do you don't even you can
kind of forget that I even put that word
there
so how does this work how do we take an
automating algorithm and use it to break
a cryptographic
well the idea is the following
uh if I have a one-way permutation
well I'm going to define the following
two formulas the first Formula has
variables x and z
and it's going to say the following well
if I evaluate X the permutation on X I
get Z and also the I if bit is zero
okay
and this other formula says well if I
evaluate Y and I get Z and the ith bit
is actually one
does that make any sense
so the conjunction of these things is
unsatisfiable right
well I mean why is this unsatisfiable
well I'm saying that two things map to Z
but they have opposite bits and it's a
permutation right so there can't be
there's only one thing that Napster said
right
so this is an unsatisfiable formula
and moreover since it's a permutation we
actually know that for every single Z I
can plug in here exactly one of these
two things is satisfiable right if if
well I mean well at most one maybe so
yeah does that make sense
okay so now here's the claim
um
we can do this for any eye okay
excellent yeah say X1 but it's important
that we'll pick it for Nei and the
actual proof but let's just yeah if you
let me say exponential
so now here's the claim if I have some
approved system which is nice and I'll
say what nice means in a second very
very mild properties on the Bruce on the
proofs
it's automatable
um and there's a short refutation of
this
function formula here that basically
just says that the permutation is indeed
a function like it has an output right
uh then you can actually take you can
actually take that automating algorithm
and invert the pronunciation
uh so what does nice mean well nice just
means that if I have a short refutation
of f then I can extract either a short
refutation of this left hand side or of
this right hand side by plugging after I
plug in some of these Z variables
okay
now here's a sketch of the proof of how
we actually see this well I'm given I
want to invert this function in so I'm
given some output some assignment to the
Z variables and I want to predict say
the if bit of the input okay
so how am I going to do it well
since the proof is nice
since the first system is nice and since
I have a short proof of f
I can just run the automating algorithm
on a x of alpha for say polynomially
many steps
after I've done this if
it hasn't
well because
the short proof of ax of alpha that
means that there's no proof of ax of
alpha and so therefore it must be
satisfiable because it was a permutation
to begin with
and on the other hand if it did halt
then this is unsatisfiable
right
and so in this case I could just run it
on the B side and I know that the B side
is actually going to be satisfiable
because the whole thing is unsatisfiable
so if a is unset then the other one has
to set this Bible
so I've turned this automating algorithm
into a satisfiability test whether or
not S A or B is satisfiable
but now just by looking at the structure
of these formulas if I know which one of
these is satisfiable I'm now able to
predict what the if input bit is given
an output of this Alpha
right and that's enough to break the
one-way permutation turns out that you
can just by predicting What's called the
hardcore bit you can just turn this into
you can eventually turn this into a
prediction of actually a full inversion
okay
this is a nice argument it's relatively
simple it fits on one slide pretty much
um so positives negatives
well
the good thing about these sort of
crypto type arguments is that they have
a very very strong conclusion right they
even rule that weak automatability all I
need is an algorithm that just outputs a
proof that a is unsatisfiable then I can
verify it right
um
and moreover if you tweak if you look at
the the strength of your cryptography
assumption you can even like bound to
the runtime of the algorithm right like
you can see there's a very tight
connection between the automating
runtime of the algorithm and the runtime
of inverting the permutation right like
the algorithm is so simple it's very
easy to extract even tight tight quite
tight runtime balance from those kinds
of arguments
um the downside of this is that we need
extremely strong assumptions right we
believe that P is different from NP and
we're happy to assume it we believe that
cryptography holds and we're happy to
assume it but I mean at some point you
know when the systems are getting quite
weak you need you start getting into the
realm of cryptography assumptions that
are so strong that maybe we believe them
but we should maybe uh hold back a
little bit so like you know for these
weak-proof systems like ac0 frega you
need to know not only is it hard to
factor numbers you need to factor
numbers of a certain type and moreover
it has to be very very hard to factor
them like we shouldn't even expect like
an exponential like a sub-exponential
Time algorithm that can Factor them
so this is kind of um unfortunate
and the reason why this only works for
these strong proof systems is because we
need to be able to intuitively reason
about cryptographic instructions inside
the proof systems itself right in order
to do this argument the proof system
needs to be able to refute this formula
which is basically encoding if a
cryptographic function you know works
and resolution we should probably
suspect can't reason about if I give you
a circuit that you know I mean we
shouldn't expect resolution to be able
to reason that this circuit is actually
Computing a one-way permutation right
so this is
roughly speaking the
what we have for these very strong proof
systems are there any questions about
this so far
so you have some quote-unquote nice
properties
so one question is what are they oh it's
right here it's just right here
oh sorry it just says if I have a short
reputation of this F
then I I get either then I can get from
that either there's a short reputation
of just one side a or the other side B
after I plug in something for the zip
variables
yeah
this is a pretty it's basically you
think you're just being like closure
under restrictions if I have a proof of
a formula and I plug in some variables
then I get a proof of this of the
restricted formula
so
contrapositive of this would be the
function is we do not important yeah and
one of these properties exactly right
yeah
so it doesn't immediately give you a lot
of positive doesn't immediately
no that's true but extended Fraga for
instance you can is nice yeah and also
has short reputations yeah this is true
this is where all the work is in fact
you have to actually prove inside the
proof systems that you can refute these
apps yeah thank you yeah thanks for
clarifying that's exactly yeah
okay so I got 10 minutes left so um I'll
kind of
I'm good I should have enough time
so let's talk about uh this Lower Side
stuff the P not equal MP and from uh the
automate ability from a p versus NP
and for this I want to go back to one of
my first slides which was talking about
the decision problems right
so we saw earlier that NP completeness
of this just decision problem doesn't
apply
um doesn't imply that automate ability
is hard because we're looking for we
need we need something stronger we need
to say not only is it hard to tell the
difference between K versus K plus one
we need to tell the difference off like
a polynomial Factor approximation in the
proof length
and all of these NP completeness results
from the 90s if you go in and look at
them what they actually get is something
like a sublinear factor
very slightly sublinear Factor off from
approximating the minimum proof right so
this gives you something in terms of
non-automatibility it says okay you
can't be off by say a linear factor
maybe that's hard but a polynomial
factor which is much more reasonable is
Out Of Reach from these
and something that that I want to
emphasize here is that all of these
results for that come from NP hardness
they're using they're studying the
hardness not of automate ability but of
the hardness of approximating this
prefix
right
this is where all of the hardness is
coming from it's not coming from the
actual finding of the proof itself it's
just coming from approximating the proof
of being hard
okay
let's again talk about resolution
um and I'll emphasize again that all
these results show that even just
approximating the shortest resolution
proof is hard
so in the 90s um you know a sequence of
works showed that uh you know up to an
additive polynomial factor it's hard to
to uh prove resolution this is just what
you get out of the NP completeness proof
If you look at it very carefully not
only is it K versus K plus one it's
actually K versus maybe K plus a
polynomial even that is
hard to distinguish unless people's NP
um the follow-up paper by Alec novich
bus Miranda potassium showed that you
know this this like slightly sub-linear
factor is hard unless P equals NP
and then there was this breakthrough
paper by Alec novich and wrote rasparov
who showed polynomial inapproximability
is hard
but unfortunately not on P versus NP but
on a on a assumption from parameterized
complexity which I won't tell you but is
a complexity theoretic assumption
um
so this was of course improved just a
couple of years ago by um at serious and
Mueller Who removed who updated this uh
this parameterized complexity assumption
into actual P versus NP and the nice
thing about um the upstairs Mueller
proof is that it it sort of relaxes
smoothly if we if you want to
approximate within a quasi-polynomial
factor well then that'll imply that NP
is in quasi-polyn real time if you want
to approximate the proof length within a
sub-exponential factor well then that'll
tell you that NP is in sub exponential
so it's actually kind of a smooth
transition here
does that make sense
so I'm not going to go into too much of
the details of this at serious military
proof but I will tell you just a little
bit about it okay I'll tell you what why
this was hard to do I think in my
opinion why it was hard to do it and why
even just kind of thinking about it is
is weird
so our goal here is to show that
approximating resolution proof length is
implies that P equals anything if I have
some algorithm that could just
approximate proof's length of the equals
entry
and so while I'm giving an NP
completeness reduction so I got to give
a reduction from set right I'll start
from sat and I'll reduce it to this
approximating problem right
but now the question is is what can such
a reduction look like
right
well it's going to look something like
this
it gets a formula I don't know if it's
satisfiable or not
if it is satisfiable then it's going to
have to have it the resulting formula
has to have a short resolution proof
if it's unsatisfiable then it must have
no short resolution
right
I haven't told you anything yet this is
basically content free if you know the
definition of a reduction right but I
want to point out that this is a very
weird thing to believe should exist how
could we come up with such a thing
um so here's a first option which I
think is kind of obvious if you just
think about it for five minutes right
well if f is satisfiable I'll output
some formula that has a short resolution
proof
and if f is unsatisfiable well then all
this output is satisfiable Formula that
has no short resolution proof right
this is one obvious reduction to do does
that make sense
now what's the problem with this
reduction
it seems like a great setup exactly yeah
the problem with this reduction is that
now I can detect if a formula is
satisfiable or not and flip the answer
for it right so if I had such a
reduction then you'd get the NP equals
column P like automatically just for
free so this just is not going to work
right
so now the second option which was the
one followed by these earlier papers was
the following if F was satisfiable
well then we'll do the same thing we'll
say it's unsatisfiable and has a short
resolution proof
and now if it's unsatisfiable I'm going
to again output an unsatisfiable formula
but it's I'm going to make it require a
long resolution proof now right and the
output is in this case the output is
always going to be unsatisfiable right
and the difference is that we want as
big a gap as possible between what short
and long is here right
but now we're in a very weird kind of
space because I'm given a Formula F and
I need I don't know if it's satisfiable
or not and I need to always output an
unsatisfiable formula how would you come
up with such a thing like it's just a
very these reductions that did this are
very intricate like in order to come up
with these types of reductions that are
very very strange you have to somehow
convert any formula into an
unsatisfiable formula
foreign
they use a different thing
um okay so what's the actual what
actually happened well
um here's the here's the series wheeler
proof well on the one hand same thing if
FS follow up or short proof
and then in the second case they're
going to Output a formula
sometimes this formula will be
satisfiable and in this case it will
have no short proof
sometimes it will be unsatisfiable and
require long proofs
um and so it was really this kind of uh
spreading the hardness across these two
things in this choice of reduction that
I think really made this that really
made this possible
so what is this RF well it's actually
um quite simple I'll just tell you the
definition of the of the reduction and
then I'll skip ahead
what does The Following
if I'm given a CNF formula in some s I'm
going to define the following
propositional formula
and the formula is kind of a meta
formula it's going to say well this
thing has a short proof even resolution
and my reduction is then going to take F
and it's going to Output ref of F and
say polynomial size
somehow not
autonomy is being inherited from the
hardness of proving resolution lower
bounds
and this was kind of the key thing so if
we think about the if we think about how
this would work well if F was
satisfiable then this ref formula is
going to be unsatisfiable and in fact it
has a short resolution reputation right
if f is satisfiable then there's no
resolution refutation at all so this
formula is unset
and if f is unset well then either it
has a short proof and so it's
satisfiable or it has no short proof and
then we need to actually prove that it
requires a long refutation and that is
where all the work is although a
significant amount of the cleverness
Cambridge is thinking to use this
formula in the first place I think once
you have the formula the lower bound
itself is not so bad somehow
okay cool
so after this at serious Mueller paper
where we got this we were able to sort
of generalize this to sort of all of
these other proof systems here so all of
these other arguments they're basically
using variants of this ref formula so
there's nothing really
well there's there's new ideas that have
to go into each of these different cases
but I mean the core of it is really
using the idea of using this reference
formula that was really the new idea
that sort of led to this breakthrough in
all these
um okay okay so in my last couple
minutes I'm going to talk a little bit
about the future and I'll go quick
because I know I'm getting quite low on
time
uh and I want to outline just like three
three obvious directions to me at least
um so the first Direction which I think
is completely obvious is to complete
this picture here
um we have these annoying sandwich proof
systems where we don't really know if
they're automatable or not surely
they're not automatable
um for these this for Charlotte atoms
and some squares is something that we've
been thinking about quite a bit and
hopefully we'll have something
interesting to say soon
for res login it seems like you kind of
need new ideas completely proving lower
interesting lower bounds for res login
is like a sort of a well-known open
problem in proof complexity itself so
this seems like a this seems like hard
and it seems like if you could make
progress on this you'd make progress
as well um another obvious thing to do
is in these results we know that under P
naught equal NP we can deduce if there's
no automatability
under crypto we can assume there's no
weak automatability can we somehow flip
these right can I somehow use stronger
assumptions
to deduce weak automatability results
down here
we don't know anything about whether or
not these weak proof systems can be
weakly automated maybe it can be right
and on the other side maybe under weaker
assumptions up here we can actually
prove that these things are not simply
not automatable this of course is going
to require totally different techniques
because we don't know how to prove lower
bounds for these systems for ac0 frega
it's conceivable that you can you could
you could make the strategy work
um
the second direction is one that I
mentioned right at the beginning of the
talk which I think is nice
um and that is can you beat these can
you give anything non-trivial about
upper bounds for these strong purchases
like anything at all anything even
slightly sub-exponential I think that
that would be interesting I think that
would be super interesting because it
would somehow say that at least once the
proof systems are very very strong you
can actually harness that somehow even a
little tiny bit would be would be super
interesting complexity theoretically or
we could bring up what Newton mentioned
earlier and that is maybe the
non-existence of non-trivial algorithms
up here could imply something
interesting in a complexity theoretic
sense that's another very interesting
Direction
and the the last thing that I want to
isolate is what Susanna mentioned at the
very beginning of the talk
and uh this was this was really her idea
I'm giving her completely the credit for
this idea which is the problem of like
finding short proofs okay
so let's go back and think about this
dumb algorithm again for a second
this algorithm ran an exponential time
to the s
well what was very interesting about it
and was different about all the other
algorithms that we saw is that it always
outputs the shortest proof right
the other algorithms they might output a
longer proof there's nothing stopping
them from not putting a much longer it's
like an exponentially sized proof this
algorithm right here is always going to
Output the shortest one no matter what
however it runs in time two to the s
right
well if you want to find the shortest
proof the question is is this actually
necessary
right or can we somehow slightly beat
the sub-exponential time even for
finding just the shortest proof itself
it's a very natural question I think
both answers would be interesting in my
opinion if you can be a positive result
would be super interesting and a
negative result would actually be super
duper interesting I'm a lower bound
person so it'd be super interesting for
me because then you would get something
like a super exponential lower Bound in
the runtime
which would be just totally cool I think
and I'm willing to make a conjecture so
for every sufficient here's a conjecture
that I'm going to make for every
sufficiently strong proof system let's
say it's it can p simulate resolution
um because tree like resolution kind of
would break this
um any algorithm that outputs the actual
shortest P proof must take this time at
least must take at least two to the S
times
seems like a totally reasonable
conjecture I don't see how you can do
anything better than just this downward
Force algorithm and proving this
conjecture conditioned on a normal
complexity theoretic assumption like say
strong exponential time hypothesis or
something like that I think is a
fascinating problem
and uh yeah that's all I have to say so
thanks for listening
[Applause]
one or two questions for the next
speaker setup
the first time it's ever happened
maybe a dumb questions but it seems like
for your dumb algorithm to make it a
little smarter by just doing some kind
of performance checks or anything to
grammar or something but that doesn't
improve your that wouldn't improve the
exponent by much right yeah the question
would be to like change the 2 to the S
to something asymptotically smaller than
asking the exponent you can certainly
improve yeah you can certainly improve
this order s in the front Yeah by doing
questions
we still have time for questions while
the next speaker is setting up so so
here's a a very in post question so
proving that
truth searches and be hard it's like
well the original problem was also LP
hard sat and still we have SATs over
solving them
so like
okay is it possible to get like a
practical theory of stone automatability
like it could because it could be just a
satis somehow Easy A lot of the time
maybe proof search is also that's
another automatically maybe also that's
easy in practice that's another great
question like in some kind of average
case extension of the theory of
automated ability is a great question
like if I assume some sort of
distribution on the tautology set I get
maybe then you can do better on average
than on finding like certainly we know
that many formulas are easy for
resolution so if I have a distribution
of easy formulas and I always find
you can there's lots of this is
something that has been completely
unexplored as far as I know like and I
think that that's a great open problem
and it's probably it is quite tied to
this sort of the one of the driving
questions of understanding sat solvers
which is like why are instances easy in
wiring since it's hard right in practice
we really don't know that
so let's all right let's speak it again
in the hope that the size
[Applause]